well the three men who want to run the
country after May the sixth are here and
raring to go
so please welcome David Cameron Nick
Clegg and Gordon Brown in 2010 Sky News
thought we've broken the mold of
Britain's increasingly humdrum political
campaigning if it's all about style and
PR count me out
we're all in this together and that's
how we'll build the big and strong
society don't let anyone tell you that
this time it can't be different it can
the president had been set and from then
on leaders debates would be a fixture of
UK elections we were wrong there have
been two general elections since then
and no proper leaders debates took place
in either of them our top politicians
have refused to go head-to-head again to
ensure leaders debates happen regularly
in future Sky News is calling for the
establishment of an independent leaders
debates commission writing to the
leaders of all major political parties
the head of Sky News John Riley said we
propose the holding of debates needs to
be deep politicized and taken out of the
control of politicians and broadcasters
for the benefit of the voting public I
am writing to you to ask that you give
your agreement and support into the
setting up of the Independent Commission
this is all about doing what's best for
the voting public at the moment the
politicians gain the debate typically
the incumbent ducks and dives the last
minute and the broadcaster's fearful of
endangering the impartiality a reluctant
to point that out the answer is an
independent leaders debate commission
that organises the debates in a fair way
well before any general election
campaign begins in 2010 voters were
given information they had never had
before the opportunity to compare their
potential next Prime Minister's and to
see them challenge one another's
policies in real time at the moment when
they had to choose between them these
debates effectively condensed the
election campaign the voters could see
what the parties
offering they could see the party
leaders and they were making vote
choices about who would be the best
Prime Minister the best party for
government Sky News his willingness to
empty chair any unwilling leader
galvanized the debates into life to the
benefit of all broadcasters we have not
worked as a team since in 2015 the BBC
pitched the top leaders against their
question time audience one by one ITV
went for multi-headed spectaculars while
Sky News opted for single programmes
there's only one way to get a referendum
and that is to make sure I'm Prime
Minister forensic ly questioning each
leader am i toughen us tough enough hell
yes I'm tough enough none of these
programs were a proper comparative
debate between potential prime ministers
then last year within hours of calling
an election Theresa May ruled out taking
part in TV debates I invite her to go to
Cambridge and debate her policies debate
her record well I mean just did you know
in the fact that Jeremy Corbyn seems to
be paying far more attention to how many
appearances on telly he's doing it was
left to the Home Secretary at the time
amber Rudd to stand in for the prime
minister do you think really the public
interest will be served if we could see
the potential prime ministers debating
together during the election time I
think the public do expect it and I
think they're entitled to it and he's
setting up a commission to try and get
that going a good idea I think it's
probably the only way to get a proper
agreement when there is a general
election no politicians don't always
agree with journalists and unusually
journalists do not always agree with
politicians so otherwise there's always
going to be a fight about it I think an
independent commission is the only way
to go from John F Kennedy and Richard
Nixon in 1962 Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton in 2016 from Washington to
Berlin election debates are a fixture
around the world many other countries be
it France on New Zealand do not permit
their leaders such Craven condescension
our politicians are to blame for this
failure but
so - are we broadcasters the lesson from
the US is that a commission can cut
through petty politics and make debates
the focal point they should be in an
election campaign
I urge those who agree with us to sign
our petition for a parliamentary debate
to set up an independent commission and
a molten Sky News
[Applause]